am I ignorant I'm going to let you
answer that question in today's episode
of ask Evan so I recently put out a
video containing Donald Trump's top ten
rules for success and I got a lot of
hate on the video I've got a lot of love
and I appreciate the love but I got some
heat on it too because he's a
controversial character and one of them
I took a little bit of exception with
where a commenter wrote in and said
you're missing my point it's about the
timing of this video you response reeks
of either ignorant or not caring about
the harsh implications of racism so
first of all I think all the loyal
viewers know that there's no room for
racism or prejudice of any kind on this
channel you can go back and watch all my
videos and I don't talk about that
anywhere in any of my videos the only
the only community that I allow you to
beat up on is the little man right the
guy is holding you back from you
achieving your goals and keeping you
down but otherwise this channel is about
believe right believe is about love is
about but education about inspiration
and I put out that video because one of
my viewers asked into one of you guys
said hey can you make a video on Donald
Trump and I knew that he's a
controversial character and I know with
any controversial character going to
people who love him again of people who
hate him and anything related to
politics is always going to be crazy
controversial and i'm doing a video on
Hillary Clinton I'm talking about Obama
in one of my presentations i did a video
of Mitt Romney and I'm not saying one
party is better than another I'm looking
for inspirational wisdom that can help
you in your life and your business so
number of people hated on the video and
that's totally cool I respect that what
it's a kiss you with what this one was
the time he was hating on the timing of
my video coming out and I want you guys
to know that I don't try to tie my
videos I don't try to time a video to
coincide with some hot trend that's
happening or on the negative side right
or something negative happens I don't
pull a video down the intention is what
is always pure right the intention
behind making that video was to answer
that person's question
ask you for that video and to help them
out and all of the comments that Donald
Trump has in the video are all for the
most part positive right there hopefully
educational giving you some
encouragement of wisdom to help you grow
your business what up Cecily what the
timing part is I'm ok if you staying for
something right if you think Donald
Trump is super racist and you are aunty
Donald Trump I'm cool with that that's
your opinion I don't have a problem with
that but when you stand for something at
certain times it bothers me right so I'm
supposed to take down this video or not
post it up at a certain time because the
timing doesn't look good doesn't jive
well with me right whatever you stand
for you should stand for regardless of
what else is happening out there in the
world so you know if I publish this
video a week later if I publish this
video next week is that okay you know
does that make it okay in your books to
me it's kind of ridiculous so if you're
going to stay for something important
that's cool but put a stake in the
ground if you're gonna hate on Donald
Trump hate on them all the time and not
only when it's in a certain window the
second part here is I believe in Milan
success and the reason why I make these
top 10 videos in in special series is
for you to pull pieces from different
people and apply them to your life I'm
not saying that any of these people are
the perfect human being any of these
people are the perfect version of you
right you can only be the perfect
version of you right you can't look up
to anybody else's say I want to be
exactly like this person in all areas of
their life only you can be that person
and my goal with making this series is
for you to watch the top 10 and maybe
you pull one two three four things that
you really like and apply that to make
you a better person and your business
grows well there's lots of stuff that
Donald Trump says that I don't agree
with there's lots of stuff that a lot of
the people that I profile on my channel
that they say that I don't agree with
either I'm only putting up filtered
content right through my lens that's
what comes through my channel things
that I think might help educate or
inspire you but don't look at any one
person and say I don't agree with one
thing that they're saying and so I'm not
going to listen to anything else as well
you know if you
only choose to learn from people who are
of a certain mold then you're
restricting yourself from what you can
learn and so again there is no perfect
person for you except you and you want
to be pulling different pieces from
their advice to make your life better
and your business better so I love to
know your thoughts am I ignorant do I
not care about racism leave with in the
comments below and I look forward to
seeing what you have to say thank you
guys for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon